i'm standing for this code review that's
how serious we're about to get heads up
guys my name is jonah welcome back to my
code review series where you guys send
me your code and i take a look at it but
today we have a very special episode i
put up a poll recently asking you guys
if you wanted to see a code review of
hazel the game engine that i have been
working on for like the last three to
four years and so
here we are so first of all what is
hazel well hazel is a 2d and 3d game
engine i see it more of like a 3d
content creation platform i started the
hazel project all the way back when the
game engine series began and then later
branched it off into two versions one
that would remain part of the game
engine series where every single line of
code that was written would be explained
and showed in the form of a tutorial
series and also the big kind of 3d
version of hazel that would be developed
off-camera and much more traditionally
as a game engine would be over the years
it's grown to be much more than just me
working on the engine at the moment we
have six or so people consistently
working on it two of which tim and peter
are officially part of studio cherno and
it is their job to work on hazel or to
make content with hazel so it's amazing
that this little project has grown into
something that
has essentially formed a studio now
hazel is still fairly early days however
over the last year we've made several
games we made forest in 72 hours
philadelphia 50. tim made this space
invaders clone and we've also got plenty
of other stuff in the works if you want
to download and play the games that
we've made in hazel you can do that
right now for free we have two games
published on our hio page forest which
as i mentioned is that latin dare game
that we made and also fragile just a
game we made in like 12 hours for fun if
you want to learn more about hazel and
hazelengine.com is a great place to
start as well as the numerous devlogs
and hazel related videos on this channel
now the reason that hazel exists and has
gotten up to the stage where it is now
with like paid staff is all thanks to
you guys the project is funded thanks to
your support on patreon where you can go
to get access to all of hazel's source
code all of the games that we've made so
far and other rewards as well so before
we begin i just want to thank you guys
the community for making this project
happen and specifically for bringing it
to this scale because i'd probably be
making a game engine on my own for free
like i was in the beginning let's be
honest however it certainly wouldn't be
my primary job without you guys so thank
you all right
i'll be honest with you guys
i have absolutely no idea how i'm going
to be able to do this code review the
thing is i usually spend like an hour or
so code reviewing the code that you guys
send me in which is usually just like
small projects and then i sometimes edit
it down to like 30 40 minutes today
though how like there's just so much
stuff to review i have a list i had to
make a list of like the key kind of
points i wanted to hit today as we dive
into this code review there is a lot
though
if there's anything that i haven't
covered that you want to see drop a
comment below i will very likely make
follow-up videos to this and in fact
we're going to use this code review as
like a way to kick off a brand new
series on my channel where we're going
to go through and like fix a lot of the
problems the thing about these code
review episodes is that a lot of the
time i
i mentioned things that i would change
or fix or do differently in your
projects
the cool thing here is that since hazel
is my project
i actually have to go through and like
there's a lot of things i have to fix so
what i'll be doing today is noticing
things that aren't right writing them
down you know coming up with
improvements and then we're actually
going to make follow-up videos where i
fix those issues and show you guys what
i'm doing so i think that'll be really
helpful because it'll be like a
practical you know real world example of
me implementing a lot of the stuff that
i talk about okay anyway let's dive in
and take a look at hazel so this is what
the kind of root repository looks like i
mean we've got some like bin folders
because i've already built this but this
is this is what it looks like i want to
take a minute and go through all of
these things talk about the various
projects that we've got inside the
visual studio solution as well just so
that we're initially aware of the
project structure now the first thing
you will have to do if you actually
download hazel and try and build it is
run setup.bat which will run a series of
python scripts that will ensure that
you've got everything set up correctly
you've got the right version of the
vulcan sdk and it will also use premade
to generate the visual studio solution
and project files at the moment we only
officially support windows even though
there is a working linux build thanks to
the community however our intention is
to of course support a lot of platforms
in the future so hazel has been somewhat
designed with that in mind now the way
that the projects are kind of structured
here is we have hazel which is basically
the core library this is built as a
static library and then used in various
applications such as hazelnut which is
the kind of level editor you know game
creation tool this is kind of like the
equivalent of like unity's editor or the
unreal engine editor that kind of thing
hazelnut launcher is a little launcher
we have just to it's kind of like unity
hub i guess a very primitive version of
that that just lets us kind of you know
see a list of projects launch which one
we want with hazelnut hazel run time is
a very important project because that is
like our game's run time what that does
is it runs like the game outside of the
editor so this is just the runtime you
give it a project it loads that project
it loads scenes inside that project and
you're off and playing hazel script core
is the entire c-sharp core library of
hazel hazel uses c-sharp for scripting
much like unity hazel script call
contains all of like the c-sharp api
that is core to hazel and then we have
scripts which is just like these python
scripts and vendor is like third-party
stuff but it's there's also vendor
folders inside the various projects so
these are just
ones that are not really specific to a
project such as pre-make now to give you
guys an idea of the size of hazel uh i'm
gonna go into hazel and source vendor
contains a bunch of third-party stuff as
you can see but if we just go into hazel
source and i run this little line of
line of code count which like lines of
code aren't obviously the best metric to
measure like a project size or anything
i mean i guess it's literally measuring
the size but if we just run this you'll
get a rough idea so we have about 76 000
lines 76 891 lines of code which is just
c plus plus and c plus plus header files
as well now this is not including a lot
of stuff this is not including the
editor this is not including the
launcher the runtime any c-sharp stuff
any like shader code this is just kind
of raw cc plus plus code and
specifically the code that we've written
as part of hazel not like external
third-party libraries or anything like
that so yeah this is going to be fun
decoder review so to dive into this
hazel dot solution is what i've got open
over here the normal kind of startup
project is hazelnut what we can do is
run that now i highly recommend running
and release we pretty much the whole
team runs and release 90 of the time we
only switch to debug for debugging
because well like any large kind of
project debug is just way too slow so
let's go ahead and run that and here we
go here is the hazel editor now all the
ui you're seeing here is rendered
in real time every frame using imgui it
has been somewhat modified so that we
can basically not have like a title bar
and it kind of behaves like a normal i
guess trendy you know modern windows
application and there are like obviously
a lot of
features to talk about i'm not gonna
focus too much on hazel's features here
although we do have if we just look at
the basic panels we have like an entity
component system with properties over
here these are the various entities in
the scene we can obviously select them
by clicking on them in the viewport we
have a content browser panel down here
which contains all of the assets that
are used here such as various like
materials and scripts and prefabs and
all of that stuff over here we have a
materials panel for like editing
materials there's a scene renderer panel
here which lets us kind of toggle
various graphics settings so if like if
we don't want ambient occlusion we can
turn that off for example we can also
see various timings for how long each
rendering pass takes we have a list of
shaders here that we can reload as well
which is very useful when we're working
on graphics and trying to write shaders
so that we can obviously just you know
change the shader hit reload and we'll
see the effects in real time there's a
bunch more panels over here as well that
i'm not really going to get into today a
bunch of project settings that we can
kind of
change over here as well if we hit play
we can obviously play the scene
and we'll
you know this is just like a little
prefab sandbox
which spawns like these cubes when you
click and shoot and all that stuff it's
playing some sound as well some of the
sound is coming from this sound graph
that we have as well if i just hit play
here you can see how we get kind of like
a random sound that's being generated
you know using this kind of visual flow
situation that we've got here and then
of course we can also go file and then
open like a whole bunch of different
projects now i mentioned hazel isn't
just used for games this project over
here is another great example of what i
like to use hazel for which is just
visualizing stuff so this scene is
actually from the latest episode of my
ray tracing series where i explained how
like these rays actually work and you
can see we basically like set up this
entire scene inside the c-sharp
scripting code so that we could like
play around and visualize how this kind
of ray tracing and raycasting actually
works in 3d space which is really cool
let's see what else there is okay so
there's forest there's forest which is
the game that we made for latin dare 50
which you can see over here this is one
of the scenes from it the kind of
initial
scene here now one of the most important
things to know if you want to write your
own game engine is math without math we
wouldn't have any of these beautiful
graphics here so many things would be
just so difficult to comprehend so i
always recommend that you guys brush up
on your mouth and for that there is no
better resource i can recommend other
than brilliant the sponsor of this video
i am dead serious when i say that if you
want to learn math if you want to get
better at the kind of math that you will
need to build something like this
brilliant is an amazing resource for
that i use brilliant myself to learn new
concepts and brush up on existing ones
such as calculus which is very important
for like the ray tracing series for
example brilliant is an amazing online
learning platform with heaps of courses
on various stem topics my favorite thing
about brilliant is just how visual and
engaging all of their courses are i find
that the best way for me personally to
learn is visually that's why i made that
last episode of the ray tracing series
where we looked at all the ray stuff
visually it's just so much easier to
understand what's going on if you can
see it and not just see it but also
interact with it and that is what
brilliant is really good at their
courses are filled with this kind of
visual interactive stuff the best thing
about brilliant is you can get started
for free just check out my link in the
description of this video but also
brilliant have been nice enough to offer
the first 200 of my subscribers 20 off
an annual membership so go ahead check
out brilliant there's no reason not to i
guarantee you will come out smarter huge
thank you to brilliant as always for
sponsoring this video anyway i could
talk about this kind of stuff literally
all day show you all the features of
hazel but that is not what we're here
for today we are here for the code so
let's dive into that okay so i figured
the best place to start is probably to
show you guys the entry point so let me
just open like a random source file here
and we'll go to the entry point so the
entry point actually is located inside
this kind of header file called entry
point dot h if you followed my game
engine series
this kind of aspect of this engine is
designed in the same way as the game
engine series version of hazel which is
basically we have this like entry point
header file and that is included in
exactly one cpp file specifically it's
included per application so you can see
it contains the main kind of function
which is either this kind of c style
main or we have like a win main which is
used for like you know if you don't want
the console this is used for the
distribution version of hazel i didn't
really talk much about the
configurations but there's debug disk
and release debug and release is the one
that we use most during development and
dist is what we built for shipping and
as you can see we have like a little
macro here that enables win main for
dist but again both of these just call
hazel main the difference is just how
they pass the arguments in and this is
kind of like the main loop of the
application kind of it looks like it
might be the one the main loop because
we have a while application running loop
here but if you actually look at the
contents of this
you can see this initializes the core
creates an application runs the
application then deletes the application
and then shuts down core so the way that
this works is this is like kind of like
our main system loop what this lets us
do is restart hazel if it needs to be
restarted and the way that we do that is
we just keep this set to true we don't
set this to false and that way when we
close the application and it gets
obviously freed from memory we shut down
core we just loop back up and we
initialize the app again and we just
started again this is useful if you if
you need to like restart your actual
game fully for some reason or like
restart the editor back when we used to
support opengl and vulkan this was used
so that we could like restart the whole
editor in opengl or in vulkan so yeah
it's pretty useful to have something
like that and we'll dive into these
things in a bit more detail but first i
want to show you where this is included
so entrypoint.h is included basically
per per project so in hazel runtime for
example we have this runtime application
we might look at this one because it's a
little bit more simple i didn't actually
show show this running but if i just
switch this to the startup project and
run hazelruntime then you can see it's
just running that same prefab sandbox
but obviously as like a standalone
application so if we take a look at
runtimeapplication.cpp you can see what
this does it loads well by default it
will load sandbox project here or like
whatever you specify in the command line
arguments it'll set up an application
specification all this is done inside
this create application function entry
point is included as you can see so that
is what includes that main function and
then the main function here will
actually call hazel create application
now hazel create application if we take
a look at the kind of declaration of
that it's just like an empty
declaration with no definition inside
hazel's static library and you can see
it says here is implemented by client
because this is us
implementing it over here so we kind of
provide that function we link that
function in ourselves that lets us write
any code we want here and the end result
needs to be like an application which in
this case is a runtime application a
subclass of hazel application which
calls like you know the base class
constructor and sets a bunch of stuff up
on init is called and that pushes on
this runtime layer another example is
hazelnut which is the editor so what
does that do that does a it's a bit more
complicated but not really you can see
that it still has this same create
application function but this time it
returns a new hazelnut application which
is just declared and defined up here
this actually already has some windows
specific code which needs to be
addressed because we should never be
writing windows specific code in generic
kind of files like this we'll talk more
about that later but you can see it like
loads like some user preferences you
know figures out the working directory
that kind of stuff and then pushes on
this editor layer so so far both of
these seem to be pushing on layers so
let's talk a little bit about the layer
system this is also actually something
that's covered in the game engine series
but basically the way that the core kind
of application is architected is any
kind of user-defined code so for the
application that you're building if you
have any kind of code that you need to
run so for example i want to render a
button as part of this interface i want
to you know render the scene or whatever
like these are all things that are not
really specific to the core application
architecture
these are all extensions of that these
are all like custom things that i'm
telling my application to do
and it might potentially differ per
application so all that stuff is
actually packaged up into a nice layer
system if we go back to entry point and
we see what create application does
right it returns an application and then
we call app run so what does this
actually do well part of creating an
application is calling the application
constructor so if we go into here we see
the first real kind of hazel class i
guess and that is application that is
like the core of every application you
can see it's located in the core here
inside hazel which is that core static
library and if we dive into the
constructor we can kind of take a look
at the main initialization code that
actually happens a lot of this doesn't
really need to be explained i think it
makes sense i hope a very important
thing that happens here is obviously
creating the window
because we need some kind of display
like a window to display all this stuff
obviously that's not really unique to
any application every application at the
moment has a window there are scenarios
in the future where we might want to run
completely headless meaning we don't
have any kind of window we don't have
any kind of real rendering api because
for example we're trying to run a server
or certain tests so at the moment hazel
isn't really set up for that but that
will probably need to change we
initialize the renderer that's pretty
much the first thing we do just so that
we can actually start rendering frames
if we need to maybe display error
messages in like you know visually i
guess not just in the log if i'm gui is
being used we create the imgui layer so
i'm gui is not something we use in the
runtime however it is technically
available we want it to be available on
linkedin just so that we can use it for
debugging if we need to in fact a lot of
editor systems are actually located
inside the core hazel kind of binary the
core hazel static library because it's
very useful to be able to run those
systems inside your runtime so like a
great example that doesn't really apply
to hazel because we don't support it but
let's just say we were running a hazel
game on our phones right what if we want
to have an overview of the scene
hierarchy see everything that's here
like there's supposed to be an entity
but we can't see it on the screen maybe
it's transform is messed up wouldn't it
be nice to be able to bring up the scene
hierarchy panel like on the phone and
just be like oh that's what the entity
transform is it would be nice that's why
like a lot of these editor systems that
you might think oh scene hierarchy panel
like that's only useful for you know the
editor like no it's also useful for the
runtime and that's the great thing about
using imgui is that like it's just
rendered using like whatever renderer we
use so if we would be using metal for
example on an ios device then you can
just render your imgui stuff using metal
you can access like the entire ui which
is fantastic so that's another really
huge benefit of using imgui
for a game engine even as your kind of
core immediate mode ui okay then we
initialize the scripting engine the
audio engine fonts you know that kind of
stuff but you can see that push layer is
kind of where where stuff happens this
is this is what we call when we override
this on init function which by the way
is called at the very beginning of
application run so application run being
called from the entry point will call on
init and start the actual main
application loop which is what this
while loop is over here we'll get to
that in a minute but first layers get
pushed on and you can see that we have
this kind of layer stack system and this
layer stack is what we will iterate
through to update every layer so a layer
is really just a class that you can
override and implement that basically
contains these various functions that
you don't really have to implement them
but you can if you want on attach which
is when a layer gets pushed onto the
stack detach when it gets popped off on
update gets called every frame on imgui
gets called every frame but within the
context of like an im gui frame so that
you can add any kind of imgui code that
you want on event is our event system so
for example every time like the user
clicks or presses a key or like the
window gets resized if we want we can
actually handle the event here because
this the event will be dispatched into
this function and then yeah we just have
like a debug name for layers just to
kind of be able to debug better so back
in application
you can see for example these layers
being updated whatever order they're
kind of pushed onto the stack that is
the order that they'll be updated in
however one thing that is a little bit
different is the way that events are
actually handled you can see that we go
backwards through the layer stack when
we receive some kind of event and want
to call the on event function that's
actually a really important function of
the event system because you can imagine
if we have two layers where maybe this
kind of base layer here is like our kind
of game we have maybe like a mountain
here or whatever a little forest with
like trees this is like our game layer
however this might be this orange one
might be like a ui layer on top of it
with like a button for example right so
if we click on the button we probably
want the click event to hit the button
first because if it hits the button
first like we might not want to shoot in
our game world because that's maybe what
left click does or interact with the
world in some way we just want it to
kind of hit the button first so that we
can then decide whether or not that
mouse pointer was within the bounds of
the button and if so mark that event as
handled meaning it will not propagate
to like layers that are below it which
is kind of how this happens you can see
if the event has been handled we just
break out of this for loop so that's
like another little detail that's
important for the event system okay
anyway i think we're going a little bit
too deep into this stuff uh so if the
application isn't minimized you know we
go through all of this we update all the
layers so you can see now why the layer
system is important because layer on
update can do literally everything in
fact it does do everything like layer on
update will do literally everything that
the application needs to do apart from
render like ui because that happens
inside like you know online gui render
which i think will happen
within like the context of a render
frame so like app render i'm good you
can see actually happens on the render
command cue which is something we'll get
into a bit later however here we have
rendering imgui we go through the layer
stack and we call on imgui render but
aside from like actual ui rendering like
that layer on update will do everything
so to give you an idea of what it does
when we're actually playing a scene or
we're inside the hazel run time layer
update will eventually go into like the
scene on update function which will like
call all of the c sharp scripts on
update functions it will simulate all of
the physics it will submit all of the
entities to the renderer for rendering
it does like literally everything this
is like really the the heart of this
entire application now getting into
editor layer this is a really big file
like if we scroll down it's what's about
3 000 lines of code it's not not huge
but it's definitely not small this is
basically the entire level editor now if
we take a look at what else is in
hazelnut like there are you know a bunch
of panels here these panels are specific
to just hazelnut because obviously we
can't use them inside just the the run
time because they're actually inside
this module we also have that sandbox
project that we were looking at this
kind of ships with the engine as like an
example project but of course you can
make your own projects as we've done for
like every game just file new project
now i want to quickly mention that like
a lot of people would look at this file
being 3000 lines and say like that's
terrible design why is it all kind of in
one file and
my answer to that is just just no just
don't say that because the thing is like
i firmly believe that having large files
is
is a good thing like it
really it's really hard to say that
because it depends on like the use case
right um
and it depends what your code is doing
but the thing is when you're working
with a game engine when you're working
with something that genuinely is
complicated there's just no way around
having
large files like
i mean yes you could break it up into
small files but why for the sake of
breaking it up into small files like
that doesn't make any sense if
everything is nicely in this file look
how easy it is to just deal with
everything i can collapse all these
functions i can easily see everything
that's here i can control f i can find
stuff that i'm looking for
because i know it's going to be in this
file if i wanted to i could have like
certain definitions or like static
variables static kind of private you
know functions within this translation
unit within all this file and everything
would be great it's faster to compile
because it's all in one file we don't
have to like look up a billion files
it's great and i'm not saying you should
put your whole engine into a file that
doesn't make any sense i'm just saying
that if you see your files getting large
and you're like uh maybe i should split
that up into another file really ask
yourself why why are you saying that
like there's nothing wrong with having a
large file maybe if it's like 20 000
lines of code and like the syntax
highlighting is struggling and your
whole ide is slow or whatever for
whatever reason maybe that could be a
good reason to
maybe split it up but like in general i
just love having all of this stuff in
one file another great example of us
having a lot of things in one file is
the script glue class this is the entire
kind of binding between c plus plus and
the c sharp scripting engine if we
collapse that and we take a look at it
like this is also like six thousand
lines of code but you can see we've got
like regions here everywhere everything
is nicely kind of separated um and
defined right we can search through
everything i actually mentioned this on
a live stream like yesterday that the
other good thing about having this
one-on-one file is when you're look when
you're trying to implement like a new
binding between c plus and c sharp and
you're trying to find an example of it
already working right because you for
example have no idea how to marshal an
array between like c sharp and c plus
plus well if all of the c binding code
is here it's just so easy to find right
you don't have to start looking through
the files and be like oh no like all
these c-sharp bindings are in like
literally each class that they bind with
like that's terrible having them all
here is just amazing and it just makes
the workflow so much easier and so much
nicer to deal with so yeah in terms of
large files like large files are kind of
inevitable when you look at a project
like this and the people who like are
concerned about certain functions being
too long or certain files being too
large like there are better things to be
concerned about i'll just put it that
way okay so because our time is somewhat
short let's dive into a specific
function here so editor layer on update
is a is a good one because what this
will eventually do obviously as you saw
in that level editor is it will render
our scene and it will potentially also
update our scene if we're in play mode
and simulate physics and do all of that
kind of stuff so how does that work well
we have several scene states scene state
edit scene state play simulate pause you
know all that stuff and based on the
current scene state this does different
things now the main kind of meat of this
is edit a scene on update editor and on
render editor as well as in play mode we
have uh if if we're not using editor
camera we have a runtime scene which is
a different copy of the scene
that we
basically will update on update runtime
and also on render runtime now why do we
have two versions of the scene well the
reason for that is when we hit play
what we do is we copy the whole scene so
you can see we created a brand new
runtime scene and we copy the editor
scene to the runtime scene why because
obviously we're going to like have to
destroy the scene in in the sense of
like we potentially need to spawn a
bunch of entities we need to you know
move the player around the map we need
to simulate physics which will move all
of them and then when we hit stop we
obviously wanted to return back to what
it was and so the easy way of doing that
is we'll just make a new scene copy that
scene and then you can have your kind of
mutable scene which you can change and
do whatever you want to and as soon as
you hit stop you basically delete that
scene that you were playing and then you
go back to just kind of rendering and
displaying and interacting with your
editor scene so that's kind of how that
works an editor scene is what gets saved
when you hit control s obviously that's
kind of like your main scene that you're
editing obviously the run time hazel run
time doesn't actually have
two scenes like this but
uh the edit for the for the editor it's
it's great so editor scene on update
editor and on render editor it's kind of
similar to the run time we might look at
the runtime because it's a bit more
interesting but on update runtime inside
the scene file is kind of what does all
of the
all the main kind of update work now
this scene is a major system we have a
little folder for it even called scene
um
i don't know there's so much stuff like
i don't know if we'll get to all of this
stuff i have a feeling i might have to
make a follow-up video just talking
about like the renderer because that's
obviously like a major system but anyway
so in the scene the scene is also big
right
two and a half thousand lines of code
this is also kind of an important class
obviously as you can imagine
so scene update and render are the kind
of big ones why do we have two separate
updates and and um and renders because
they do different things like we could
do a better job for sure of like
combining some of these things so if you
look at on render runtime and on render
editor a lot of these things are similar
like for example the way that we render
the lighting is identical um it's just
that i think the
really to be honest the major difference
is probably just the camera so we use an
editor camera for on render editor
um and for simulation as well but then
to render runtime we obviously use like
whatever entity in the scene has
like a camera and it's also the primary
camera so that's what we kind of render
from right so that that's really the
only difference i mean there's some
other you know setup code that's
specific to like this camera entity that
obviously doesn't exist but aside from
that we probably should combine the
functions because they are
they are similar and the way that it
currently sits means that we have to any
changes we basically make to the
rendering
inside scene we then have to also make
to simulation and runtime which is just
asking for bugs so that can definitely
be improved but the update is quite
different because on update editor you
can see it really just updates the
animation so that we can like still play
like our kind of skeletal animations uh
in kind of the scene view however um on
update run time is you can see it's it's
huge it does so much stuff um so let's
kind of begin with the top so the first
thing we do is we update box 2d so and
this is when we hit play this is where
i'm actually playing like a scene in
hazel so updating box 2d obviously
important uh if you have 2d physics if
you don't
like this is another thing right most 3d
games that we've made in fact every 3d
game that we've made and shipped does
not actually have box2d like we don't
actually use box2d for anything yet we
are still at the beginning of every
update being like hey man do you have
box 2d world components and like let's
make sure we update that you know that's
obviously useless because there's not
going to be any bodies
any box 2d bodies within that box 2d
world even though yes the world will
exist technically because the scene
always creates it that's something that
definitely does not need to exist right
so
we could probably scrap this um this as
well just won't run really this forward
won't run because when you ask the
entity component system for like all of
the rigid body 2d components you'll get
0 if it's a 3d scene well again there's
nothing just to point this out you can
definitely combine 2d and 3d physics in
one scene there's nothing to stop you
from doing that that might be useful in
some cases not saying this doesn't need
to exist i'm just saying that if you
know for the 3d games we've made we
haven't used 2d physics for anything
within those 3d scenes and so because of
that this is something that we could
exclude in fact if we were really being
pedantic about this we probably don't
want to link box2d in to the engine at
all right we probably want to not
compile with that because when we ship
our game and we look at like the exe
file this will build statically so it'll
all be built into like a single exe file
all of these things no dlls really for
anything except for mono and i think
asim as well for like 3d models and
stuff but basically because all this
stuff is built not with dlls like it
will mean that the binary size grows a
bit i mean like the binary size isn't
that large if we take a look at a game
such as like forest for example if we
look at the actual forest dxe so this is
kind of the build result right
everything gets built into forest.exe
which here you can see is like eight
megabytes so it's not massive and then
we just have these two dlls which are
kind of like the dependencies that are
not statically compiled so in other
words we have about 25 megabytes of
total binaries that are necessary for
this actual application so not too bad
at this stage as the engine grows though
i'm sure it will be it'll be it'll get
larger anyway moving on from box 2d we
then have the actual physics scene and
this is the 3d physics scene so for
physics we use nvidia phys x uh at the
moment that's kind of like our physics
back end we call physics scene simulate
we have our own kind of api on top of
that which again is something that we
might explore in like a later video you
can see it's in the physics folder here
we have 2d which is kind of box 2d and
then we have the 3d which is like physx
stuff so this is all of our api on top
of physx to kind of manage everything um
so yeah lots of stuff obviously here uh
but physics scene simulate will
eventually like call into physx and
actually update it so you can see
there's an advanced function over here
and then we do physx scene simulate
which is already going into like nvidia
physics stuff and simulating our scene
this function will also kind of
re-synchronize any transforms so once
physx actually simulates the scene it
moves entities and all of that within
the scene it's just moving a transform
and then we have to take back that
transform and apply it to the entity so
that will take care of all of that the
next kind of stage here is updating all
of our c sharp scripts so games in hazel
are written in c sharp just like in
unity so we obviously have to go through
and call the on kind of on update
function on every entity which is what
this will do over here every single
entity in the scene that has
uh basically that script component and
has an entity instance here it will uh
it'll call the on update function and
then there are certain things that we
can't do in the middle of an update so
we submit them to a post update queue
that's this comes from c sharp so any
submissions from c sharp will get
processed kind of after all of the
entities have finished updating which is
what happens here animation gets updated
audio over here gets updated as well
this is this is all still like audio
stuff we have quite an advanced audio
system if you haven't noticed by that
graph earlier and that's kind of it
that's everything that happens as part
of the update now render if we take a
look at render runtime that is over here
that does all the rendering now you may
have noticed that uh these are basically
called sequentially so we have like on
update runtime and then on render
runtime right these are called all from
the same place now rendering doesn't
actual rendering stuff doesn't actually
happen immediately rather it gets
submitted to a render command queue
which ideally would be processed on a
separate render thread which is the
architecture that i've designed hazel to
work with from the beginning or it could
still run in a single threaded mode as
it does at the moment and it could just
go through that render command queue on
the main thread but like after all the
updating which is how it currently works
so in other words like vulcan draw calls
and all that stuff won't actually happen
inside this function that'll happen
later inside application.cpp we have a
render await and render function which
again ideally would run on a separate
thread and we will move to that
architecture i'll probably make videos
talking about how we move to that
architecture because it's coming very
soon but basically this will go through
the render command queue which is
actually a custom command queue that
i've written here the main reason for
this is to make sure it doesn't allocate
memory it allocates the entire like 10
megabyte buffer in this case up front
that's hard coded which probably isn't
the best idea probably needs to be able
to resize and everything but uh this
will kind of pre-allocate 10 megabytes
worth of commands which are basically
function pointers as well as any data
that you copy as part of your function
and then that gets kind of executed here
just by going through all the commands
and finding like the points to the
function as well as the kind of
parameters and executing the function
over here so that that will happen over
here even though currently we are inside
layer on update now back in on render
runtime you can see we yeah do stuff
like set the camera viewport size we go
through and kind of construct this
little light environment which is
contained some information about
directional lights we really only
support one directional light at the
moment so that's what we're kind of
seeing here point lights however we
support like well
a lot we use ford plus rendering so uh
we can have like a million of them
probably um but i think realistically
the hard limits that are just put in the
shade at the moment is 1024 point lights
which we haven't needed needed to really
exceed but again we could have as many
as we want all of the point light data
can just be stored in the storage buffer
that you can resize to be as as big as
you want so uh that's that's kind of how
it works here we have a bunch of point
lights which are just entities which
have a point like component will go
through them and just set them up into
the light environment and yeah i think
this is over here what this is this is
actually a vector but in the shader i
think it's
it's said to be like 1024. we have a sky
light at the moment which is really just
like a an environment map so we use this
for image based lighting in our
rendering so that's how it's kind of
finding it here and if we don't have
one we just create like a black one this
is necessary just so that we can send it
to the shader and we have like data to
read from otherwise what this is doing
is basically either generating a dynamic
sky so we have like a dynamic sky
compute shader using like the pre-themed
sky model so we can set up a bunch of
parameters and it will actually create
one that's what's happening here it's
kind of like a memory only asset that
will get created by your game at runtime
if you're using that otherwise you can
read in like an hdr
equirectangular map which are basically
like the kinds you'd find on like
polyhaven.com hdri so see this kind of
equirectangular format you can download
any of these in this kind of format and
just
slap them into your
to your skylight component basically so
that's that and then we finally do
renderer begin scene which is
kind of the beginning of the scene
renderer which is the class that renders
all of our stuff which is also 3 000
lines of code
and
i'm telling you this code review man so
i think seen renderer we will probably
save for a different day probably make a
video just talking about the rendering
in hazel because basically scene will
call into scene renderer and scene
renderer will then call into like a
static renderer class
uh and then that will actually execute
like the vulcan render api commands and
all that stuff and submit them to that
render command queue so that's a that's
a rather big system in and of itself so
once we've called begin scene which just
gives us kind of like some context uh
then we render all the static meshes
we're under all the dynamic meshes and
then like you know physics debugging you
know visualization and all that stuff if
we need to as well we then composite in
any 2d rendering on top of that so you
can see we get like the final pass image
we set that as like the target render
path and then we go into there and you
know draw any sprites which are
currently disabled um as well as like
you know text rendering um in 3d space
so this is if you have like a text
component basically i think you guys saw
in that prefab sandbox scene there was
like some explanation text so all that
would be rendered here
uh any debug rendering that we've done
from c sharp as well will kind of show
up here and that's kind of it that's the
end of that function now there's
obviously it's like so much more like
stuff we could look at here um but i'm
beginning to think this might be a good
natural place to kind of end this first
video that shows kind of an overview of
how the engine comes together how the
application loop works how the scene
like update and rendering works as well
from here i think the next thing we'll
look at in a separate video will be
specifically like the renderer because
i'm sure that a lot of you are
interested in how all the rendering
works and how it comes together so we'll
definitely take a look at that i think
i'll also make a video talking about the
performance of hazel so we'll bring up
some of the tools we use for profiling
and see like the problem areas that need
to be improved and then we'll actually
see if we can improve them i've also got
a long list of things that need to be
like fixed
re-architected refactored re-implemented
whatever and my idea is hopefully to
show that happening in the form of like
this series basically i just don't think
there's much point in me showing you all
those problem areas now it's probably
better to like focus on each area per
video or something like that anyway let
me know what your thoughts are regarding
something like this this is obviously
like a huge project and it's difficult
to kind of
code review and go through everything
here so hopefully this was somewhat
entertaining and informative to you guys
if there are any other engine systems
you want me to kind of extensively talk
about as well then definitely drop a
comment below and let me know as i've
mentioned feel free to play some of the
games that we've made in hazel for free
i'll leave links below and if you want
to support the project and get access to
all of this source code and the entirety
of hazel and patreon.com is where you
can go for that if you have an
interesting project that you want me to
take a look at as part of this code
review series then email me at
channelreview gmail.com i'll have like
some details in the description box
below but other than that i hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button don't forget to check out
brilliant using my link in description
below as well and i will see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you